seit knapp einem jahr stecken wir in
dieser pandemie und in den nachrichten
habe ich gehört dass deutschland aktuell
hohe schulden macht diese schulden wir
haben sie aber nicht alle abbezahlen
können denn sie gehen in ein paar jahren
in rente und der großteil der schulden
bleibt an uns den kindern hängen
daher ist es wichtig dass alles für
unsere bildung getan wird
ja das mit den schulden ich finde das ja
auch gut dass die schulden gemacht
werden weil den menschen muss ja
geholfen werden
aber wie gesagt wir müssen ja alle dann
abbezahlen und das geht so nicht weiter
denn distanz unterricht ist eine gute
lösung für kurze zeit
meine schule macht das auch super
darüber will ich mich gar nicht
beschweren
leider ist es nicht der
präsenzunterricht und ich schreibe hier
auch sagen was ich an distanz und
richtig gut finde
erstens es ist schwierig für uns kinder
dich für so lange zeit alleine an einem
schreibtisch zu konzentrieren
außerdem fehlen uns an unsere freunde
und lehrer der für uns sehr wichtig sind
und es haben ja auch alle nicht die
möglichkeiten wie die anderen kinder
manche kinder haben kein eigenes zimmer
oder keinen internetanschluss oder halt
keine gerät ja wer weiß was hinter den
geschlossenen türen bei den familien so
passiert manche kinder haben auch ganz
andere probleme
und wie sie sehen ist es sehr wichtig
dass wir zur schule gehen
was wollen sie denn dann tun also dass
das wieder regelmäßig funktioniert also
würde ich zweigeteilt antworten als
erstes die schuldenfrage dass du völlig
recht ich bin immer ein großer fan davon
dass man vielleicht mal in der
schwierigen zeit schulden aufnimmt so
wie jetzt aber dass man sonst sauber
wirtschaftet ich war selber mal
finanzministers ich habe genau diese
dinge bearbeiten müssen und ich habe
alte schulden immer zurückbezahlt ich
habe alte schulden in guten zeiten
zurück gezahlt weil wir in deutschland
ist in den letzten jahren cameron
gemacht haben treffen uns die jetzigen
schulden weniger schlimm als andere
länder die schon immer schulden gemacht
haben und gar nichts zurückgelegt haben
verstehst du also sie haben also
generell im leben man lebt ja mal was
zurück verschlechtert sein
das haben wir relativ gut gemacht und
wir kommen im moment deswegen auch
besser durch als nahezu alle länder der
welt denn das schicksal ist praktisch
überall das gleiche
also es gibt ein paar länder die
schnelle mit der pandemie fertig
geworden sind die entweder den vorteil
haben dass sie eine insel waren sowie
australien also nicht immer wieder die
grenzen man auch ansteckend hatten oder
ein system haben das wir nicht wollen
die in china wo einfach alle do
eingesperrt wirst wenn du so eine
situation heißt also dass mit den
schulden ist ernst zu nehmen dass ich
bin ja dagegen wie manche jetzt in der
politik weil die wollen einfach alle
dämme öffnen lassen und sagen macht die
schulden auf dauer ist nicht gut weil du
hast recht das müsstest du bezahlen und
das ist nicht fair und es ist auch nicht
gerecht automatisch also kann sie da
verlassen ich jedenfalls soweit ich das
kann
achtet darauf dass das alles in maßen
ist und nicht übertrieben wird und das
zweite mit der schule noch mal ich teile
deine auffassung dass eines der probleme
des landes und s2 das einfach das
erleben miteinander auch die sozialen
fähigkeiten
jetzt kann man versuchen das natürlich
wir versuchen so gut wie möglich
auszugleichen erster recht also der
distanz unterricht ist nicht besser als
der präsenzunterricht ist immer
schlechter aber er ist besser als gar
nichts deswegen habe das gemacht und du
hast auch recht dass es im kinder gibt
die probleme gerät während es in bayern
so gemacht dass wir eben noch mal ich
glaub ich mach dir aber auch geräte
kaufen sowohl für lehrer als auch für
schülerinnen und schüler um da auch das
voranzubringen
dass man mit wlan und breitband versucht
es überall möglich zu machen und am
anfang zeige ich dir ganz ehrlich weiß
nicht so leicht hat nicht so gut
funktioniert und jetzt scheint es mir
halbwegs zu funktionieren soll aber
nicht dauerhaft sein
mit den konzepten von mehr testen lüften
maske glaube ich kann ein schrittweises
zurückkommen in die schule da sein und
ich sage es auch ganz ehrlich am für
mich hat schule immer ist die nummer
eins weiß es gibt sehr viel diskussion
ich sagen dies muss geöffnet werden und
jenes muss geöffnet werden
da gibt's sogar debatten darüber jetzt
muss wieder den fußball bundesliga muss
jetzt alle stadien voll machen
also ich sage mal in der in der
reihenfolge seid ihr das wichtigste
schulen kinder sind das wichtigste weil
ihr seid unsere zukunft und
so sehe ich das für mich ganz persönlich
in meiner familiären situation als auch
für dich und daran lassen wir uns messen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren